these these folks I'm talking about
Hollywood the university's a lot of the
folks in the meat not all of them many
of them in the media these are the
purveyors of political correctness and
they were winning see here's the thing
we Americans are by nature polite we
follow rules we care about not offending
other people we want other people to
feel respected we actually like each
other for the most part and we're not
all that interested in taking off our
neighbors but the left finally went too
far maybe it was the specter of the
President of the United States tacitly
nodding at riots and major American
cities or maybe it was the feeding
frenzy media declaring over and over
that founding ideology was dead and had
to be replaced with something new and
shocking maybe it was a culture that saw
every single traditional value is an
obstacle to be destroyed or overcome or
maybe we just got frustrated with the
lies whatever it was the American people
finally said enough we said enough we
said no you don't get to lie about
America and no I won't lie about America
even if it makes you feel better if I do
we said you don't get to tell little
boys that can become little girls just
to avoid offending people you don't get
to slander members about members of our
police departments across the country
about calling them racists without any
evidence
[Applause]
you didn't get you do not get to claim
against all available evidence that
women are paid less for the same work
you don't get to suggest Allah our good
friend bunny sandjas that's stealing
money from some and giving it to others
makes you a moral human being it doesn't
it's the reverse and we said most of all
you do not get to shut us up
[Applause]
well what changed the left finally
pushed too far Americans realized that
we were being turned slowly but surely
into weaklings older Americans realized
their kids were being taught to play a
victim instead of thinking for
themselves they realized that children
who think their victims won't actually
take control of their own lives right
everyone in this room is capable capable
of success it's a free country everyone
in America is capable of success if they
apply themselves and if they follow some
basic rules or if they get a job if they
don't have babies before they're married
if they graduate high school they do
those three things you will not live in
permanent poverty in the United States
younger Americans realize they were sick
of being pandered to that they didn't
need to be told how rough they had it
they needed to be told they could
accomplish anything in this the greatest
country in the history of the world
[Applause]
women men black Americans Hispanic
Americans white Americans didn't matter
millions of Americans thinking as
individuals rather than checkmarks on a
piece of paper standing up and saying I
can do what I want I can say what I want
and if you don't like that you can go to
hell
[Applause]